for me reinvention is really being about
adapting to change no matter what
challenges come about in life and one of
the things we always talk about A to Z
that is a characteristic we really value
is being able to thrive under
uncomfortable and uncertain situations I
think that is a huge part of being a
start-up entrepreneur and reinvention
definitely at the core of what we do
[Music]
when I first was coming up with a
company I was actually in China
consulting at a number of textile
manufacturing companies and we were
seeing all these headlines where a lot
of their clients were literally burning
billions of dollars of inventory but
being their clients they kind of had
revenue targets to hit so for me a
building choosey was really about
reinventing a new era of retail where we
use data to drive our decisions and in
doing so create less excess waste
because we're not just producing
whatever we think of seasons in advance
I met both my co-founders my first job
trading on Wall Street so I think what
completely shocked them and made them
first decide that this is something
maybe worth looking into was when I was
literally shipping thousands of packages
from my apartment it was like chaos it
was sewing machine like logistics
fulfillment center and it was just like
who is this person what is this company
[Music]
I think it's a completely different
ballgame when you know your shoppers are
not at the physical places where
retailers used to meet them but now that
they're online and how do you create
experiences that meet the consumers
where they are and I think from the
retail perspective for the first time
ever you're really able to utilize some
of these new technologies as well as
like revolutions and supply chain to cut
smaller runs which means you could if
you're married Ana driven be a lot less
wasteful and hopefully in another 10
years we'll never see headlines about
companies burning him in to worry again
[Music]
you